it happening right in front of your ass
commentated by me and mark man it's been
such a pleasure man
shout outs to astro as well as shout
outs to b esports for making this happen
i'm having a dope time so far mark man i
hope you are too bro
i i'm having a great time and and looks
like joey's about to have a great time
because he's switching over to [ __ ]
rob
you know he had the marduk he had the
paul earlier on that went into those
matches
they didn't work he lost 3-0 in our
winners finals but now he's switching it
over
to [ __ ] wrong i'm gonna tell you
right now we actually saw him do this
before when he was playing
i believe it was ben chang in the icfc
uh finals
when he got that w that's when he
switched to playing a
[ __ ] rhyme i believe aro was versus
cuddle corner it was versus cuddle four
yeah yeah he definitely picked uh faka
rum
only for cuddle core he was able to do
it with martic in the past but this
switch
will be interesting because we haven't i
don't think we've seen these two play
this particular matchup in a while
let them know i still got this hot kick
on deck let you know i still got this
hot kick on deck
nice and look at that the patience here
from joey fury dashing in
waiting for these opportunities just
been opening them up with these these
quick lows
oh he was he ducted he was ready to go
oh he's trying to snap his neck oh the
double orbital the disrespect
big damage good adjustment there from uh
claudio
binchang really putting in work there
with that sequence
but you can't count them out you cannot
count them out
i like the defense punish
round three i like it i like it fight
no break on the throw
nice look at that he's just dashing and
waiting in his face again waiting for
these opportunities
guaranteed down four i like that option
though just you have to wait against a
[ __ ] mom i feel like
and be aware of some of the options that
he has been change is also
a pokemon player that we've seen before
so
very tight defense on both sides oh yeah
he's definitely just keeping them there
they trade blows look at that has him at
the wall looking to close it out but the
delay not able to confirm
oh my gosh committed too much to the 1-1
okay all right all right two rounds to
one bin chain
remember this is loser's side for joy
fury so he needs two sets
eats the counter though he's definitely
gonna be going to the wall because of
that
jose oh tries to get the rewa split
maybe the flip over with the hop kick
but it didn't hit
nice good block there
able to get the punish here goes for the
grab
joey waiting for this opportunity gets
the big counter hit there
should be
didn't even need the wall two rounds a
piece in his first game
all right we're going down to our final
round here as mentioned joey fury in the
loser side of our grand final so he has
to win
two sets of matches to be our champion
here
but bin chang's gonna have a lot to say
for it here he's definitely been doing
work with this claudio
stupid very careful so quick oh
and just did it and just did just
committed to it after blocking the
string
that was so smart by ben chang takes
that first game
away from joey feud and you see joey
fury was just
zoning and he was like if i get right
here you're gonna have to respect it and
then he was like
no once you block this i'm just gonna
challenge and make sure that you don't
get to
apply that pressure ben chang is a
[ __ ] wrong player he's gonna know
the angles you trying to approach you're
trying to get that final shot to take
down the big ship
not gonna work not against me because i
play that character i'm one of the big
names
yeah i mean he had starburst he had the
move locked and loaded he was ready to
spin it to win it
and you know what he just was like you
know what screw it i'm gonna do it i'm
gonna make it work and
he got it he got it yeah i mean
anyways if you guys are tuning in right
now obviously there's been a lot of tech
and stuff that has happened today as you
mentioned steve
we got our new shirts we have the king
of the hill finals going on we have the
new character
trailer that was just launched for lydia
of course uh follow the tekken channel
for more information on that
uh later on throughout the day but it's
been a fun day and we're not even at the
end of the king of the hill finals we're
in the middle of grand finals now but we
still have the challenge with glaciating
that is going to be coming up and it's
going to be one of these two players
your thoughts steve on who it's going to
be though
i mean in all honesty i'm not sure the
last these last few matches we've seen
these guys play before this is a run
back from icfc we just saw in one of the
last weeks of icfc
joey fury beat ben chang if i'm not
mistaken to win the entire tournament
and now
we're getting the run back here at the
king of the hill finals
this is gonna be good and then we have
another run back which could be
potentially a big run back
which is that back and forth we've seen
all season one through icfc
all the way back to the preseason
between bin chang
and glaciating our king of the hill
challenge winner so we get to see that
no matter what this is gonna be or some
really good ass tekken that we're gonna
get here on the back end once again the
counter hit working out and ben chang
is looking like the one to go on to face
our king hill challenge if he keeps
going like this
oh yeah he's doing such a great job and
really kind of containing
bakumram here and joey fury but joey
look at this he's he's starting to work
his way he's he's working his way around
using these pokes he picked the open
stage you know he obviously feels a bit
more comfortable in the matchup
so to not be constrained at least
movement wise right
but now joey playing a lot more compact
a lot more
oh nice a lot a lot more um small wager
in some of these things not making like
the biggest gambles and not giving the
opportunity for bin chang to get these
punishes
okay goes for the load really trying to
open them up here but again
threat here of that counter hit double
kick it could have been something big at
least you see joey fury starting to get
the wind of some of these options
and that could have been like a wild
standing three that could have been you
could have been dead
or very close too yeah he does have a
good lively right now but a big launch
here from bing chang vincent going to
close it out with some damage with the
running too
let's see what he does here he does have
uh life a bit close to each other
there's a sidestep or again
and i think the trademark and really the
strength of a claudio player is how he
uses his limited
uh reach with the lows that sidestep
four he's been so good at that i don't
think it's really been blocked
too much in the way that he's been using
it oh here goes joey fury
fighting back he got two rounds on him
now
okay
oh look at this the way he's just adding
it up yeah this offense is definitely
just stacking up for the side of ben
chang at this point
two round lead here for joey fury though
definitely not over yet
oh that could have been he could have
did back one and got a full launcher
right there
just a little hesitant when it comes to
pulling the trigger on some of these
punishes
get off him hands off delay i just won
this bad boy
oh yeah wow the sidewalk
gets away from the orbital and once
again the challenge
ben chang's still alive that's got to be
a lot of pressure to be able to
kind of fight a character like [ __ ]
romp up close at that range and to trade
blows them like that he has had
he definitely used claudia as a main for
a reason he is so confident
in his character and his space oh my
gosh
look at that look at that 4-3 full combo
extension big damage
[Music]
nice 1-1 follow-up here look at joey
joey working on
on that pressure puts himself into rage
all the superman punch one of the things
we haven't seen to get too much use uh
today especially in this set but it's
definitely getting some right now
gets the round on top of it
this is big because you know you do not
want to give bin chang a 2-0 lead
you do not want to have that he just
took half life from bing chang with
nothing but pulse
oh yeah bing chang trying to answer back
with a few pokes of his own
look at the range that bin chang's
playing at and once again joey fjord
the march of the popes the hopkins to
cut through it all
this could be the momentum shift that
bing chang needs will he be able to pull
it off okay
joey chilling on the floor
wow oh my gosh the jab interrupt the low
he had it right there yeah that could
have been it that could have been the
round
it could have been the match and instead
joey fury takes it
just didn't believe just had to commit
to that and did not
joey fury gonna be able to steal that
with the [ __ ] around
and now we got a match we got a match
now
we definitely have a match and it's
gonna be interesting from here now tied
up right it's tied up
i mean what are you going to do so
you're binching you do have some
insurance because you have a set lead
right
and we know binge i could use a number
of characters but if he feels like his
claudio and his spacing and his timing
is getting downloaded or it's it's going
to prove to go against him i wouldn't be
surprised if he switches characters
uh i would not be surprised it's it's
not it wouldn't be unlike him right
um i would really like to see i feel
like that's one of the things i've been
waiting to see
just while we've been playing online is
like for ben chang to get some run backs
and see how he adjusts
to some of these characters that's what
i've been interested to see and i think
that we could potentially see another
character
but the confidence how much control he
gets with claudio
it's a it's a little bit much i feel
like he really has
uh joey fury kind of playing at odds
where he's still trying to gauge a way
to come in and i think this is better
for him for the time being now this
round comes out and joey fury has like a
dominant lead it might be time for
switch
possibly but i think that's his main i
think claudia was such his business
character that he was willing to stick
to the character and just make
adjustments
well either way i think it's hard to
pick uh we're gonna go to the character
matchup now let's see which character he
picked if he made a switch at all but i
mean he's a claudio man we know that's
his best character right
i think everyone can confidently say
that and he is going to stick with them
as we go into this next matchup it's
tied up one apiece here between bin
chang and joey fury
as these guys battle out to go up
against the current king of the hill
glaciating
and and by the way we didn't talk about
it too much but glaciating
has been doing work with miguel real
talk he has been doing so much work with
that character and it's so cool to see
that
i mean but even now if you think about
it it started switching to the girayu
uh the danny as well right yeah as well
and then
and still able to get like victories
with the paul another character that
we've seen him play
does float and you're on the wall and
bing chang had a read there on the
timing
extending the knee hit into the
follow-up launcher
ended up working out for him right now
he's looking pretty damn comfortable
here in this matchup oh
he ducked he got up and he got hit he
got clipped
i think we tried to hit a button right
there because i feel like that's the
right way to deal with it you fuzzy
right there
and then if it's too slow then you still
get the block on while you're standing
up but
just try to hit a button down one plus
two the punch barry hits down four
one coming from joy fury what an answer
and i feel like that's how you keep
up close pressure honest with aquaman
that down 4-1
okay nice i like the low jab attempt
there
oh and the magician's four i like that
magician for
oh yeah
i mean you can't see but he got his
stand equipped right now too
uh-huh only stand users can see it oh
okay that makes sense that's why i can
see it oh nice while standing three here
we go that should be able to close it
out here you go straight into the rager
and joey fury is going to go up
two rounds to one here again in this
very very close set that we've been
having so far
oddly enough when it comes to the pace
i'm always thinking that bing chang is
going to be the person
who comes out on the other side when it
comes to like you know the patience game
but
joey fury just slowly but surely keeping
it close
has the round lead right now actually up
in the set two rounds to one in game
number three
i mean i gotta say you know bitching is
one of those players that has been able
to dominate
and has dominated in uh in months past
especially with these online events
i feel like his presence in these
brackets has definitely leveled up the
play from
every player that's been involved too
oh my gosh okay hey let me let me get
that round back give me a bubble here
bro two rounds a piece game number three
set tie one one grand finals
it doesn't get any closer than this more
pokes more honesty
trying to make them keep it especially
from [ __ ] rum i get it and i'm sure
ben chang understands too
look at it tries to move after the block
superman
punch eat the back two because
more jabs
dancing a whole lot right now joey fury
finally gets down one plus two to hit
and there's those down four ones once
again tries to fuzzy block the low i
know that's what he was doing
i know that's exactly what happened he
was looking for the low in the string
still got hit by the mid
small punish ben chang and rage
spins the blue goes for the mid block
and a duck this time around on the down
for
joy fury one game away
from sending us to a reset versus ben
chang
if you have watched icfc you've seen the
back and forth between these two players
and i'm pretty sure
i'm pretty sure joey fury won the last
time and now we see the
we see the point of joy fury get knocked
to lose his side
fights his way through and gets the run
back versus ben chang again
that would be crazy that's what
potentially we could be seeing right now
and bing chang you know he doesn't want
to lose here he does not want to let
joey fury reset
this the the series because if he does
he's going to deal with a whole new
monster a whole new beast
so that being said i feel like maybe if
there is a chance to switch characters
this might be it
this might be it also i feel like bin
chang really wants
he wants to take out glaciating no
matter what like just
to beat him because right now i feel
like if you look at like some of the
results outside of you know joy's theory
outside of cuddle core
um ben chang and glaciating have been
two of those players that have
historically gone back and forth this
entire season um
and the last victory i if i'm not
mistaken came on the side
of glaciating right so glaciating versus
ben chang
went to glaciating last time and they
have i don't think they've gotten a
chance to play since
at least not in tournament this is gonna
be that chance if he can get through
joy fury ben chang can get that faded
run back
with glaciating but we gotta get through
this first this is first to three
on loser's side nonetheless joy fury's
gonna need two sets
and he's going to stick it through and
he just picked a random stage he is
wanting to get in there he's like get
out of my way i just want to play i just
want to fight
get out of my way all right this is a
big one
joey fury up 2-1 here in this opening
set of grand finals small punish right
there on that back one
i gotta say it feels good to do
commentary and to be able to share tech
in with you guys on the official tekken
channel again it's been a long time it's
definitely been facts like
it's it's and it's been a good time not
a good time for being shane though the
little perry you're gonna get the ball
uh huh uh marching baby back turn tech
that quick tech on the wall you gotta be
careful the unblockable
yo you know what sucks getting hit by
your own thing bro and then bing chang
has hit many
people with it sidestep four goes for
the mid down four one to check it
and then he hit him with the stutter low
the stutter low
and then bing chang hit one more out i'm
sorry i said ben chang because i was
thinking about him playing uh [ __ ]
around
all of us yeah he started with everybody
i like that though he dashed in he
waited then he pulled up
the cheeky low joey fury continuing
his rampage right now
oh my gosh oh my gosh and that's one of
the situations where you can press that
wildstanding
instance and if they do something big
after that that counter hit four is
gonna work out just like that
ben chang joey fury one game apiece game
number four
if joey fury wins this match if he can
we got one more
before we get to see who's gonna be the
winner here of this king of the hill
challenge it's been a dope season
tournaments all around oh oh down back
three
40 seconds left on the clock why's that
move so fast there's the walk
side step four again and then the down
four i love the patience
joy fury one round away for reset yo if
you want to reset let me see
one in the chat and if you don't let me
see it too if you want joey fury to take
it
this is your chance big change fighting
back he's doing so well
with that running too that's superman
punch he's making it work
creating that spacing game for himself
right now he's gonna have to be careful
big
[ __ ] wrong pushing has his back to
the wall this could be a good spot here
for binchang if he's able to take
advantage of the hits four one plus two
oh and the wheels keep spinning every
time i stop like the wheels on the bus
oh oh big damage
okay a sliver a sliver erotic care
erotic care the only thing between joy
fury and a reset
will this be enough well this stimulus
package helped me save my family
the block on the low and ben chang
bin chang trying to stop the reset going
right back in
potential final round if joey fury can
close this out
we will get one more set to determine
the reset will be in full effect
the trooper roll to send us home
claudio bing chang
stops the reset oh my god dude
it's gonna be well we're down to our
final match here in set number one right
so
there this is the story where we're at
joey fury he needs this match he
obviously needs this match and he needs
to win another set
however bin chan can end it all here and
earn his way to fight against glaciating
our current king of the hill
all he needs is one match he's obviously
locked into claudio this is all on joey
fury on which character he's gonna pull
out for this single match
take it one step at a time this single
match
well now this this is gonna be important
if joey fury wants to stay alive right
if joey fury wants to continue fighting
this match is pivotal you have to win
this match
are joy fury's out of it he will be
getting second place he will be going
home but let's stay on the positive
let's stay with a positive mind said
joey fury has a chance to reset
if he can win this match but will we see
a character switching mark that's what i
want to know if you had the guests right
now and you're pretty good
at making these calls man would you
switch characters
will we see joy fury switch for one
match no
i don't think so for for i feel like
since he's done so much work with fakam
already
i feel like he's not gonna [ __ ] around
he's gonna go
he's going to stick with [ __ ] bro
okay all right here we go i could be
wrong
i mean you know we we know and it comes
down to you know your main character
we see bin chang he's using claudio
that's obviously his main right now i
feel like
the main character for joey fury is
still marta that's what i feel like okay
okay well let's see let's see boom
bakaram sticks to his guns joy fury
versus ben chang's claudio
this uh this next match is gonna be a
big one
if the reset happens so this is the
thing
it's like he did pick he did switch he
switched stages and that's a big one
no walls
they're already going back to the pokes
could have had a full combo conversion
there actually gets him the whiff
but no nothing coming from
all right here we go this is going to be
important he goes for the back one
doesn't get it
and right now again life lead here for
bing chang puts joey into rage where
it's obviously dangerous he was ready
without wall standing too
he said not in my house not in front of
my kids
in front of my family okay okay
count back three
nothing big the superman big damage
the approach from bing chang good luck
good point he's ready for it yeah he's
so ready for it
bitching looking full blown control at
this point right now
no more rounds can be lost no more
rounds can be lost i'm not sure
but it feels like bing chang has been
making joy fury play a lot more honestly
and that's why i said at the end of that
last game i'm like bro you might have to
die
you might have to switch man
is crazy right now the way that bing
chang is playing he's in total control
of the match up here joey's gonna have
to pull out a miracle he needs three
straight rounds
to even have a chance tall order tall
order here against bing check
call back around yep
i don't think he's taller than mario no
no
he is here on paper trailer oh no
oh here we go 18 seconds left on the
clock
look at the time one game away one round
away
from securing his trip to the king of
the hill
run back against none other than
glaciating
joey fury gonna take second and that
means he's out of the tournament
and that sets up the king of the hill
fight we're gonna have glaciating go up
against
none other than ben chang the ic
fc run back we need to get a nice little
package together so we can display the
people
on icfc what happened the tale of the
tape how we got here
this match is going to be good we've
seen glaciating go at bin chang before
we've seen the character switch now a
lot of the times which is oddly enough
and the reason i'm gonna say this is
because